yeah when you said that Mike kind of
rolled his eyes so clearly he knows Rex
as well as we do well Mike Lucan first
of all welcome to the show well thank
you so Mike how did you get involved in
the Chess Club in the activities here I
know you're a board member well very
early on when Rex was still employed
moving back to st. Louis I had the
opportunity to meet him and over a
single malt scotch one night he we were
talking about movies and I said I really
loved searching for Bobby Fischer and
Rec says do you play chess I played a
little in high school and he says just
just like this he says if I had a
chessboard right here right now would
you play for a hundred dollars so i said
well i would there was no chessboard
around we're at the ritz-carlton and he
disappears 45 minutes later he shows up
with a chessboard to make a long story
short I lost a hundred dollars leaving
we became friends and some years down
the road when he started the the Chess
Club he was nice enough to ask me to
join the board well I can't believe you
fell for that one though that was a
sucker's bet but I hear that now you
guys play online and that to his chagrin
you beat him more games than that he
wins against you fortunately I've had
some good teaching and how's this
possible first of all jen is his coach
as well so Jennifer is coaching Rex
coaching user is there a little money
being paid under the table there to make
sure the results go the right way well
the way that works Maurice is Jennifer
likes me better so I'm happy to say I've
won two out of the last three and the
earlier record really doesn't count it's
all about right here right now I
appreciate that so I know you're
president of General marine services
tell us a little bit about your company
well general marine services were a
barge service company we do Steve
adoring work we also do Co packaging
work so we handle bulk materials on the
inland waterway provides storage and
Steve adoring services for a variety of
clients and each assets be
passed along these barges not on there
are a few of our captain's that play and
enjoy a game but not while they're on
duty so tell us the benefits of chest as
you see it why you're so involved how it
affects the kids in the community well
we're we're big supporters of Loyola
school here in st. Louis and we've seen
the effect that those young people this
is fourth fifth sixth graders what chest
does for them and that's just a small
part of what chest is done in this
community and across the country and the
club promotes that and makes it
available along with teaching and it's
really special well we think is special
we appreciate the contribution that you
make to chess here in st. Louis and to
the young people and thank you very much
for joining us oh no problem thank you
for having me Mike Lucan president of
General marine services and he owns Rex
that's what we know I like that in the
last three games that's a great way to
look at life like you're in a conflict
of interest every Tuesday match up
against each other you can control the
outcome